(swoosh)
(bang)
- Hello Believe Nation, I am thinking
about writing the top ten
rules for success as a book.
And I want your feedback on what you
think of how to make it better.
So a little bit of context,
growing up, this was
one of my favorite books
as an entrepreneur of all time.
What it basically does is
in like four to five pages,
let me see, let me pull up one.
One, two, three, four, five,
A.P. Giannini, that's my
favorite entrepreneur.
So one, two, three, four, five.
Basically in five pages tells their story,
what made them successful,
and I would read one of those pages,
one of those stories at least every day
just to get me motivated,
give me strategies
as well as the kind of
motivation to keep going.
And I've been getting a lot of requests
from people that say when are you
going to do the top ten series as a book.
And I'm wondering, is now the time?
Is now the time to do it?
And what suggestions, ideas, feedback
you might have on how
to make it a success.
I'm thinking something the same lines
of condensing the
interviews and the videos
that we have down into four to five pages
on each entrepreneur telling their story,
sharing their wisdom,
basically the top ten.
But all crunched down into five pages
that maybe you can read on the subway,
or on a trip, or on the
beach, or if your commuting
to work, or just when you sit down
at your desk every morning,
kind of like what I did
when I was reading this book.
And I just want your feedback.
What do you think?
Good idea, yay, nay?
Suggestions on how to make it amazing,
awesome, your favorite book of all time.
Let me know, I'd really appreciate your
thoughts and suggestions.
You guys mean a lot to me, and I really
value opinions and feedback.
So please let me know.
Leave a comment.
Maybe it'll happen.
And if you guys don't
like it, maybe it won't.
So let me know guys.
Thank you for watching, I believe in you.
Hope you continue to believe in yourself.
- [Nina] Be whatever you want.
- You want to come in Nina?
Nina loves the spotlight.
Okay, believe in yourself.
- And whatever your one word is,
we'll see you soon.
Bye.
- You missed the much love.
- Oh, much love.
- Much love
- Much love from the Teamo
and from the Teamo, okay.
But seriously, let me
know in the comments.
(swoosh)
(bang)